[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous pour
cette édition spéciale du soir 3 2 puis
et bientôt trente six heures de
terribles images nous parviennent des
états unis au lendemain des plus graves
attentats terroristes de l'histoire
c'était le 11 septembre 2001 c'est à
thiers et cette date restera à jamais
ancré dans les mémoires
ce qui est arrivé était tout simplement
impensable mais ce que les américains
ont découvert ce matin et est pire qu'un
cauchemar c'était tout simplement la
réalité
le bilan humain est toujours impossible
à évaluer des milliers voire des
dizaines de milliers de victimes
pourrait être sous les décombres des
deux symboles de la puissante amérique
le pentagone et les tours jumelles de
manhattan
selon les autorités américaines
l'enquète avancent très rapidement
les terroristes ont même été identifiés
pour commettre ces quatre
attentats-suicides les kamikazes avaient
tout prévu tout préparé dont le plus
grand secret au lendemain de cet acte de
guerre comme l'a qualifié de george bush
on commence à comprendre ce qui s'est
vraiment passé dans les quatre appareils
détournés
jennifer alberte un peu moins d'une
journée
c'est le temps qu'il aura fallu au fbi
haye pour obtenir les premiers résultats
dans son enquête au cours des dernières
24 heures et les indices que nous avons
examinés l'audition des familles nous
ont permis d'identifier je crois la
plupart des la principale piste a mené
les enquêteurs dans cet hôtel de boston
où des suspects seraient descendus
plusieurs personnes ont été interrogées
pour l'instant pas encore d'arrestations
mais de sérieuses pistes permettant de
reconstituer l'itinéraire des
terroristes
de leurs complices une enquête qui
révèle déjà les coulisses de l'opération
et quatre avions ont été détournés par
trois à six a dit du paraguay utilisant
des coûts thomas et cutter et dans
certains cas nos nations de faire
exploser les bombes
le fbi a ya également découvert que
certains pirates ont suivi des cours de
pilotage sur le territoire américain la
maison blanche et l'avion présidentiel
air force one faisait aussi partie des
cibles visées
quant aux commanditaires tous les
regards se tournent plus que jamais vers
le milliardaire saoudien ben laden
ennemi public numéro un aux états unis
et dans quelques minutes juste après
cette édition nous vous proposerons un
document exceptionnel sur justement
oussama ben laden et ses réseaux
terroristes qui par le passé ont déjà
visé les intérêts américains
ce soir officiellement une quarantaine
de corps ont été retrouvés sous les
gravats mais le travail des sauveteurs
ne fait bien sûr que commencer toute la
nuit et toute la journée les équipes de
secouristes ont tenté de retrouver des
survivants dans un paysage irréel de
villes bombardées
huguette au petit matin manhattan
ressemble à une ville de science fiction
un épais nuage entoure les gratte-ciel
environnants mais les plus orgueilleux
de ces mastodontes de verre et d'acier
sont à terre deux tours sous lesquels
les secouristes s'acharne à retrouver
des survivants
malgré l'épuisement hommes et machines
s'activent le temps est compté parmi les
miraculés retirés des gravats
trois policiers ils ont tiré avec leurs
armes afin d'être repéré par les
docteurs wii 2 blancs sûr qu'il y encore
des survivants sous les décombres
on a des indications il arrive à
communiquer avec leurs d'ailleurs la
nuit dernière on a extrait deux
policiers vivent les militaires se sont
emparés des rues avoisinantes et boucle
les carrefours
image saisissante d'une ville en état de
choc d'un pays victime d'un acte de
guerre
les hôpitaux sont débordés deux mille
personnes y ont déjà été admis
beaucoup sont dans un état sérieux on a
vu des gens qui était brûlé le corps
entièrement brûlé il y avait aussi des
victimes dont les voies respiratoires
étaient endommagés on a dû pratiquer des
trachéotomies on a vu aussi des gens
souffrir de multiples et sérieuse
blessure éplorée photo à la main les
familles des disparus se pressent devant
les hôpitaux
chacun raconte son histoire en quête
d'un indice d'une nouvelle réconfortante
mon fils m'a appelé hier après
l'explosion du premier avion
il m'a dit qu'il était dans la deuxième
tour et qu'il lève actuelle il était
environ 9 heures 5
depuis nous n'avons plus de nouvelles
l'encastrement d'un troisième avion dans
le pentagone aurait provoqué la mort de
800 personnes combien en reste-t-il sous
les décombres fumants de ce qui fut le
symbole de la toute puissance américaine
on ignore mais la vision de ces civière
recouverte de draps blancs est de bien
tristes augure comme nous touche vous
avez été choqué hier de voir en direct
ou quasiment en direct les avions
s'écrasent et les tours s'effondrer avec
un peu plus de recul nous allons tenter
de mieux comprendre ce qui s'est passé
en plein coeur de manhattan
grâce à de nouvelles images filmées par
des témoins voici ce que les new-yorkais
ont vu et vécu stéphanie perez
8h45 une banale intervention dans les
rues de new york
quand soudain un grondement sourd
ce pompier y prête à peine attention
et pourtant
l'impensable vient de se produire
on était au 51e étage on a entendu c'est
énorme détonation
l'immeuble a tremblé violemment du mal à
te le red bull on a tout de suite su que
quelque chose de grave était arrivé et
le cauchemar vient seulement de
commencer 18 minutes plus tard la
deuxième des tours jumelles explose à
son tour sur cette vidéo amateur filmée
depuis la rue la boule de feu ravage
tout sur son passage en face dans les
bureaux
l'incrédulité puis la panique
[Musique]
et ce n'est pas fini
une heure après les deux tours de 290
milles tonnes chacune s'effondrent comme
de vulgaire château de cartes
[Musique]
bruno de laage est employé d'une société
lyonnaise est sorti de l'immeuble juste
à temps
[Musique]
la nuit est tombée et puis incendié puis
une molécule terre vraiment ce quartier
est un champ de guerre que c'est
absolument invraisemblable je crois que
c'est surtout du point de vue émotionnel
la peine que l'on éprouve pour tous ces
gens qui sont restées dans le bâtiment
parce que je suis parti restait encore
des tas de gens c'était ce qu'il y avait
tous ces pompiers qui monte pour sauver
des gens et tous ces gens là sont des
scènes d'apocalypse
ce médecin film tout
la fumée était épaisse l'obscurité
angoissante
ils cherchent désespérément des
survivants à aider est ce que quelqu'un
a besoin d'un docteur le nez au milieu
des débris humains ils nous trouvent que
des sauveteurs
impuissant la ville est engloutie sous
la fumée
en fin de soirée un troisième building
voisin mettreen towers s'effondre à son
tour sous le contrecoup images
saisissantes digne de l'un de ses films
catastrophes dont raffolent les
américains mais hier à new york
il ne s'agissait pas de cinéma
ah ah
et on direct de new york nous retrouvons
carine azzopardi karine le silence est
il toujours impressionnant aussi
impressionnant à manhattan ce soir ou
bien la vie at elle commencé à reprendre
tout doucement
bah non c'est assez incroyable quand
même vous voyez derrière moi il ya quand
même un nuage
un épais nuage de fumée qui recouvre
encore la ville mais alors que des
dizaines de milliers de personnes sont
encore ensevelies sous les décombres que
des offices religieux à la mémoire des
victimes ont été célébrés un peu partout
dans tous les quartiers de new york
la vie ici est madame reprend on entend
du bruit on entend de la musique des
chansons la circulation les magasins ont
rouverts petit à petit les restaurants
le bruit revient en fait à l'heure
actuelle la ville et comme et comme
coupé en deux un gros tiers de la ville
au sud de la 4e rue est totalement coupé
du reste du monde c'est une sorte de no
man's land maison peuvent sortir mais ne
rentrent pas n'y a toujours pas
d'électricité à l'intérieur tout à
l'heure j'ai marché pendant trois heures
demandant dans ce secteur j'ai croisé
des véhicules de police des véhicules de
pompiers déchiquetés et des gens
complètement hagard et juste de l'autre
côté des barrières on pouvait voir une
scène assez surprenante des terrasses
ensoleillées avec des gens qui qui qui
se restauraient tranquillement à 100
mètres du ballet des véhicules
militaires qui est entré dans le secteur
pendant qu'on y est karine j'imagine que
les sauveteurs poursuivent leur travail
pour tenter de retrouver des survivants
oui évidemment il ya toujours des
milliers de secouristes qui travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour est pour essayer de
retrouver les survivants mais jusqu'à
présent on n'a retrouvé que que neuf
personnes sous les décombres il ya des
dizaines de tractopelle qui étaient
alignés dans les rues à côté de la 14e
justement qu'ils étaient prêts à entrer
en action ce qui n'est pas très bon si
mes équipes sont épuisées et on voyait
des sauveteurs qui sortent j'en ai
rencontré des secouristes qui me
découvrais qui me décrivait pardon d
des scènes d'horreur de ce qu'ils
avaient vu les morceaux de corps d du
sang des vêtements de la poussière mais
tout est toujours irréel ici parce que
la vie reprend d'un côté et aussi
incroyable que ça puisse paraître
merci carine azzopardi en direct de new
york après le flottement ressenti hier
au sein de l'administration bush le
président des états unis a repris les
choses en main il a promis des
représailles à l'encontre des
commanditaires et des pays qui les
soutiennent
et comme toujours en cas de crise dans
l'histoire américaine c'est l'union
sacrée
aucune polémique députés sénateurs
démocrates et républicains sont tous
solidaires
julien colombani tous les membres du
congrès sont derrière george bush qu'ils
soient républicains ou démocrates
c'est l'union sacrée tous travailleront
de concert ont ils affirmé
pour répondre à la crise pour aider les
victimes
pour punir les responsables et bill
clinton en visite en australie l'a bien
résumé l'unité nationale sera totale il
est absolument impératif que le peuple
américain montrent au monde entier son
unité
il va y avoir des décisions difficiles à
prendre
on travaille dur pour savoir qui a fait
ça
90% des américains sont prêts à une
riposte militaire s'il s'avère qu'un
pays a soutenu les terroristes là aussi
l'opinion publique suit son président
les attaques délibérées et meurtrières
ont été menées hier contre notre pays
était plus que des acteurs de terrain
elles étaient des actes de guerre à new
york
la solidarité s'organise des centaines
de personnes ont spontanément offert
leur sang on a même dû refuser du monde
par manque de personnel infirmier
tout ce que nous pouvons faire
aujourd'hui pour aider est important
c'est juste un petit texte puisque
rapport à la souffrance de certains
vous êtes les héros de new york merci
clament ces banderoles de fortune au
passage des secouristes
petit à petit manhattan reprend vie les
principaux axes routiers le métro et
quelques liaisons aériennes ont été
rétablies la zone autour du désastre
reste encore interdite les secours
tentent toujours de dégager des
survivants
les terroristes ont frappé les états
unis mais l'ondé de choc a été ressenti
dans le monde entier même fidel castro
s'est montré solidaire israël a décrété
pour sa part une journée de deuil à
l'exception de l'irak tous les pays
arabes ont condamné ces attentats
yasser arafat a présenté ses
condoléances au proche orient les gestes
symboliques se sont multipliés
aujourd'hui nora boubetra yasser arafat
en personne est venu donner son sang un
geste hautement symbolique à un moment
de l'histoire où le président
palestinien est considérablement
affaiblie de gaza à jérusalem les mêmes
gestes cette fois ci il s'agit du
président israélien moshé katzav partout
dans le monde le même élan de solidarité
un élan qui donne parfois lieu à des
scènes surréalistes comme ici à cuba le
président fidel castro
l'une des bêtes noires des états unis
tendant la main à son voisin
[Applaudissements]
notre peuple est solidaire du peuple
américain et appelait chasse ou total
pis aux scissions et on a la totale
disposition des états mais dans la
mesure de nos modestes moyens quand la
médicaux sur kameni terre et contre
notre coopération pour accompagner une
aide aux victimes au même et à lui
baissé par vladimir poutine lui a donné
son feu vert pour une minute de silence
en l'honneur des victimes
pour le président russe le terrorisme et
la peste du 21e siècle
sentiment partagé par la population
venue nombreuse se recueillir devant
l'ambassade des états unis à moscou dans
l'ensemble des pays arabes ont condamné
ces attaques sauf en irak selon saddam
hussein les etats-unis n'ont fait que
récolter les fruits de leurs politiques
néo phase réaction sévère également en
jordanie le roi en général plutôt modéré
les témoins aujourd'hui il n'y aurait
pas d'attentats si les états unis
avaient réglé le problème du
proche-orient at-il déclaré sur cnn loin
des discours politiques le silence de
rome ils étaient des milliers ce soir à
illuminer la ville de leur soutien une
lumière qui il l'espère apportera un peu
de réconfort
outre atlantique jacques chirac qui a
décidé de maintenir sa visite à
washington prévue mardi prochain un
voyage au cours duquel le président de
la république rencontrera george bush
de son côté lionel jospin a mis en garde
ce soir les états susceptibles
d'accueillir des groupes terroristes sur
leur sol je vous propose tout de suite
d'écoutés le premier ministre il faut
donc aussi responsabiliser les états
seuls les états peuvent faire que les
ans les relations internationales
restructurer et il est bien évident que
c'est de leur responsabilité de lutter
dans leur territoire contre le
terrorisme ne pas encourager des visées
terroristes
sinon il risque d'en subir le poids
en france il n'y a pas de menace
identifiée daniel vaillant se veut
rassurant néanmoins le ministre de
l'intérieur a justifié le renforcement
du plan vigipirate
pour ne prendre aucun risque les
journées du patrimoine prévue ce week
end ont été reportés aujourd'hui
policiers gendarmes et militaires ont à
nouveau pris position dans les endroits
stratégiques comme en 95
à l'époque de la vague d'attentats sur
le sol français
reportage pierre nicolas fabrice launay
cette voiture éventrées dans une rue de
paris n'a pas été la cible d'un attentat
mais victime du zèle des démineurs elle
était garée au mauvais endroit devant
l'ambassade du canada
l'alerté maximale la phase 2 du plan
vigipirate
c'est aussi le déploiement de plus de
4000 hommes policiers et militaires dans
tous les endroits publics et notamment
les hauts lieux touristiques contrôles
renforcés tout azimut mosquées et
synagogues protéger centrales nucléaires
surveillait de près les risques
d'attentats sont pris très au sérieux
tout le monde est sur le pied de guerre
ce qu'elle veut dire et la police à son
niveau
ainsi que les forces armées qui sont
venus en renfort est également en état
de guerre puisque
c'est quand même une atteinte à la
démocratie et à toutes les valeurs de ce
que défend la république française en
province comme ici antibes
l'idée d'une crise à venir entraînent
des réactions digne de la guerre du
golfe
la crainte d'un krach pétrolier créé
d'impresionnantes files d'attentes dans
les stations service si ça continue
comme ça on risque d'être en pénurie
d'ici trois ou quatre jours de carburant
bien qu'ils aient pas réellement
problème d'approvisionnement c'est
vraiment un problème lié à la panique
des gens on n'en est pas encore à
stocker de l'huile et du sucre
le ministre de l'intérieur demande de
raison garder
le dispositif vigipirate renforcé
découle du principe de précaution et non
d'une menace directe sur la france elle
pourrait exister en cas de riposte des
états unis avec le soutien de leurs
alliés français dans ce cas vigipirate
sera encore renforcée d'un cran les deux
tours du world trade center abritait de
nombreux société étrangère parmi ces
entreprises certaines sont françaises la
cellule de crise ouverte au quai d'orsay
a reçu de très nombreux appels
aujourd'hui des personnes inquiètes
évidemment pour leurs proches qui
travaillent à manhattan
pour l'instant aucune victime de
nationalité française n'est à déplorer
le crédit agricole qui possède à une
filiale aux 80 deuxième étage d'une des
deux tours a appris avec soulagement ce
soir que ses deux employés français
n'était pas présent au moment du drame
vous voyez le numéro de cette cellule de
crise le 01 45 55 et 80 00 les
américains qui se trouvent actuellement
à paris sont évidemment plongés dans
l'angoissé
la plupart d'entre eux n'ont pas de
nouvelles de leurs proches qu'ils
travaillaient à manhattan ou au
pentagone à washington
une communauté sous le choc qui a
assisté ce soir à une messe célébrée à
notre dame de paris par monseigneur
lustiger une cérémonie oecuménique en
hommage aux victimes
yann fossurier joy banerjee à des
milliers de kilomètres de new york
l'hommage aux victimes de la tragédie
une messe de la paix ce soir à notre
dame
un moment de recueillement pour une
communauté américaine profondément
meurtri
on a perdu quatre personnes que nous
connaissons au world trade center
notre fille tient un commerce à bas qui
est grâce à lui elle n'y était pas mais
les gens qui travaillaient pour elle
sont tous morts
un sentiment d'impuissance face à une
tragédie sans précédent
à paris l'université américaine est en
deuil la psychose commence à gagner les
étudiants on avait peur d'aller dans le
métro on avait vu que tout le monde
enlevé leur drapeau américain et puis
c'est une catastrophe
ils étaient nombreux cet après midi à se
réunir dans les pubs pour suivre en
direct l'évolution de la situation
ma fille aux etats-unis a de nombreux
amis qui travaillait dans une de ces
tours je suis inquiète car elle attend
encore quasiment même et nouvelles de
ces personnes
ces familles certains auraient aimé
regagner leur pays dès aujourd'hui mais
tous les vols en direction des états
unis ont été annulés les américaines
france s'apprête encore à vivre de
longues heures d'angoissé et je vous
propose de voir les dernières images qui
viennent de nous parvenir
celle notamment du travail des
secouristes qui travaille depuis
maintenant plus de 30 heures
ils recherchent bien sûr toujours
d'éventuels survivants
le dernier bilan officiel fait état je
vous le rappelle d'une quarantaine de
morts mais c'est désormais une certitude
des milliers voire des dizaines de
milliers de personnes se trouvent
toujours enfouis sous des gravats et
j'apprends à l'instant qu'une partie
encore érigé de la tour numéro deux du
world trade center s'est effondré en fin
d'après midi heure américaine
c'est ce qu'a annoncé la chaîne de
télévision cbs
concernant l' enquête un mot pour vous
dire que le fbi a annoncé ce soir avant
avoir identifié tous les terroristes ou
les kamikazes qui se trouvaient à bord
des quatre avions qui se sont donc
écrasé hier sur le sol américain
voilà ce que nous pouvions dire ce soir
concernant cette tragédie mais restez
avec nous car dans un instant france 3
vous propose un documentaire
exceptionnel réalisé par la bbc en 98
mort à l'amérique c'est le titre une
enquête édifiante sur le suspect numéro
un de ces attentats le milliardaire
saoudien oussama ben laden réfugié
depuis cinq ans maintenant l'afghanistan
ce document inédit en france a été
réalisé après l'attentât meurtrier
contre l'ambassade de nairobi
l'ambassade américaine c'était il ya
trois ans vous découvrirez les
nombreuses ramifications de ce très
puissants réseaux implantés dans une
vingtaine de pays une enquête qui nous
éclaire sur ce qui s'est passé donc hier
aux états unis
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
du soir 3 très bonne fin de soirée
tout de suite le documentaire mort à
l'amérique
[Musique]